All right.
Today I want to talk about,
uh,
what I think of is one of the most significant failures of environmental law in
the 20th century.
Uh,
and this is the way that we manage toxic substances.
but this is a story that is more about,
uh,
not just the individual chemicals,
but also,
uh,
the products that are created when chemicals are merged together.
They're,
they're synthesized.
So what is the plastics problem?
In part,
it's the enormity of the industry.
Uh,
about 119 billion pounds now produced each year in the United States.
This is a roughly about a $400 billion industry.
And I mentioned earlier that,
just to give you a point of comparison,
uh,
to the pesticide industry,
the pesticide industry produces about 10 billion pounds.
Uh,
so it's about 10 times smaller than the plastics industry.
And,
uh,
the,
annual sales from pesticides are about 10 to $12 billion per year in the,
in the nation.
So compared to the attention that a pesticides have been given,
uh,
over the past 30 to 40 years,
the plastics problem has been just about fully neglected by Congress,
although it did pass the toxic substance control act back in 1976.
And this law was intended to encourage premarket testing of chemicals.
And what we'll see today,
he said the majority of chemicals,
uh,
remain untested,
that the ingredients are unlabeled.
Uh,
the country of origin is unknown for and for most products,
the recovery rate is exceptionally low.
Uh,
and recycling failure occurs for many reasons.
but,
uh,
and we'll look,
we'll explore several of those later in,
in the,
uh,
in the session.
Uh,
environmental contamination at a global scale,
uh,
has occurred.
There are plastic particles,
molecules in ambient air outside and indoors,
uh,
plastics who contaminated underground aquifers as well as surface waters.
In many parts of the industrialized world,
there's been universal human exposure that exposure is chronic.
You get it on a daily basis.
And,
uh,
the health effects that we now are beginning to understand a have to do
predominantly,
uh,
with endocrine disrupting compounds,
chemicals that are mimicking human hormones.
Uh,
we rely unfortunately for the most part on animal studies to,
uh,
give us some insight into what the effects on humans are likely to be.
Uh,
but we rely on that evidence for many other classes of compounds as well.
So this,
this area has received,
uh,
virtually no attention from the environmental protection agency.
And I want to talk a little bit today about why that is.
So 850,000 people employed in this industry,
uh,
at number three 79 is now up above $400 billion per year.
Uh,
and plastics comprise 70% of the synthetic chemical industry in the nation,
including 500 different resins.
Plastics labeling is confusing to many people.
You may not,
uh,
look on the bottom of,
of,
uh,
a milk carton or you may not look a on the,
on the back of a,
uh,
many different products to look at the recycling code.
The recycling code in the United States is completely voluntary.
There is no legal obligation to post or the chemical content,
the origin of the plastics,
or what should be done with it once the product is discarded.
So give you an example here.
Polyethylene hat has the symbol number one.
So I,
bottled drinks such as a Pepsi and Coca Cola are packaged in pet.
Sometimes it's called Pete a polyethylene.
Uh,
there's a high density version of that,
which is number two,
and there's a low density version of that,
which is number four.
So carrier bags and a bin liners for example,
as opposed are the low density polyethylene as opposed to say,
uh,
the,
gallon milk jugs,
which are the high density polyethylene.
Uh,
the polyethylenes are the most likely to be recycled among all plastics
polyvinyl chloride,
uh,
by comparison,
PVC for short,
uh,
[inaudible] is contained in many different products,
water pipes.
And I'll show you some examples of that in a few moments.
Uh,
it's almost never a recycled,
which means that it's either buried or it's burned.
Once it,
uh,
is finally discarded polypropylene.
Uh,
you may,
you may find polypropylene in,
in,
uh,
rugs.
He can find it also in a margarine tubs,
different kinds of food packaging,
uh,
products.
Uh,
but also in a,
the microwavable meal trail,
meal trays,
polystyrene,
most people don't understand what styrene is.
You,
you are all familiar with styrene balls.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's also an absorbent material that's put at the base of,
of meats,
uh,
in packaging.
And a,
I mentioned to you that uh,
uh,
the packaging problem is especially related to food is incredibly complex.
There's no way for you to know what chemicals are in the packaging materials
that you buy in the grocery store.
Uh,
seven is reserved for other kind of plastic resins so that they,
the only those that do not fall into the other categories are given the number
seven and we'll,
we'll concentrate on one of those today,
which is called [inaudible].
Is,
is what's used to form polycarbonate plastic.
It's very dense,
very hard.
And often it's in clear form.
It can be colored.
So Nalgene bottles are a good example of a number seven,
uh,
the polycarbonates.
And,
uh,
also you might think of the,
the head lamps on,
on a car or a motorcycle helmet or advisor.
These are all examples of,
of polystyrene,
or excuse me,
polycarbonate here is a chart that lists the recycling rate in yellow for all
the different classifications.
And you basically see pbcs,
uh,
are at the bottom of the list.
So PVCs are not recycled because the chemical content is so complicated.
Uh,
the highest degree of recycling occurs with a polyethylenes.
So the Pete bottles,
uh,
have a,
roughly,
uh,
20 to 25% recycling rate on average in the United States.
And this is highly variable by,
by a region and the nation.
And also by my time of the year,
uh,
the polypropylene is almost never a recycled,
nor is polystyrene poly carbon.
That's the hard plastic composite,
uh,
that,
exist.
For example,
in my,
my glasses.
Uh,
these are also almost never recycled.
So what happens to them?
I'm gonna take you on a quick cook's tour of plastic in your life and you'll
remember that I challenged you to think,
to try to find out if you could avoid purchasing plastics for a week.
And if you are able to do that,
I challenged you to avoid using plastics for week.
And I believe that,
that,
uh,
today is a virtual impossibility.
So I started to do a little inventory in my own life,
uh,
and uh,
actually got quite disturbed at myself and my own ignorance and a what I had
exposed my family to.
Uh,
and I,
I became extremely interested in trying to,
to,
uh,
kind of reconstruct a why I was so clueless about,
the thousands of different products that,
uh,
had made their way into into my life and into my family's life.
A contact lenses are a good example on their hard contact lenses and they're
soft contact lenses.
The hard lenses could,
could contain a Biz Faena lay as polycarbonate,
the software contact lenses that will change their shape,
uh,
with your eye or as a rotate,
across a,
uh,
a surface that is not completely even,
those,
those contact lenses normally contained Falaise.
Phthalates are softeners.
So bis fee and La is the hardener,
uh,
validates or softeners.
And these valleys are a particular problem with respect to a one which is
called,
uh,
die.
FFL Eight.
Dehp that I'll talk about a little bit a little bit later.
My daughter wears a retainer,
a,
she's 10 years old.
My youngest daughter,
and I don't know what's in that,
but I would imagine that it's predominantly polycarbonate.
Uh,
she wears it,
uh,
about 12 to 15 hours per day.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
most people have dental sealants.
Dental sealants are pretty interesting,
so that a,
you can test people's saliva after the dental sealants are put in and you can
find,
uh,
the Biz fenal a,
in the saliva.
Uh,
also there's a protective characteristic of these sealants.
They prevent you from getting cavities,
uh,
that would demand putting a different kind of plastic into your tooth or a metal
amalgam.
And many people in my generation,
my parents' generation,
uh,
have,
fillings in their mouth,
uh,
that include metal amalgams,
including compounds such as mercury.
So it's a very interesting kind of a trade off.
One might make
you think about a different,
uh,
other sources of plastic in your life.
Most of you are probably familiar with that smell of the vinyl shower curtain
when you first opened the package.
And for a couple of days it's offgassing in your bathroom.
Different kinds of clothing,
uh,
raincoats fabrics,
a Gortex for example,
are made out of of a different plastic,
uh,
resins.
And these also are generally non-recyclable.
Uh,
and I want you to think about the built environment.
When a house is built,
uh,
in the northeastern part of the U S it's generally framed out of wood.
Uh,
you see the plywood there,
that's being tacked onto these two by fours or two by sixes.
Uh,
and then you see the,
the plastic sheeting that,
uh,
is being attached a made by dupont called TYVEC.
A TYVEC is,
uh,
is a,
an interesting,
uh,
product and that it,
it seals the house from mold.
And that also has a protective effect in that molds are known to,
to threaten human health and,
and a induced asthma or,
or exacerbated,
uh,
as one example.
Uh,
but this product also is extremely rarely a recycle a tyvec.
Also,
you can find in a variety of different settings.
Uh,
here's,
uh,
Tyvec a disposable coverall,
that is claimed by the corporation to protect against more than 150,
a hazardous chemicals.
So for those people that work with hazardous chemicals,
uh,
here's a product that helps to protect them.
Uh,
the idea of it being just stoked disposable caught my attention.
It's advertised as being disposable.
Certainly,
uh,
you know,
most things are disposable,
but that doesn't give you any clue about where they might end up eventually in
the environment.
In this case,
uh,
this will not break down for,
probably,
uh,
hundreds,
if not thousands of years.
Now think about a house.
This House has plastic,
uh,
in many different areas.
It's got the vinyl siding on it.
It has pillars.
You can see,
uh,
pillars here in the front and over on the side.
You might think those pillars are formed out of wood or perhaps a that they're
ceramic,
but,
uh,
they're generally plastic.
Uh,
you see the light post,
that's plastic as well.
Uh,
you see the,
the railing on top of the,
the front porch,
uh,
near the front door here.
This is also a,
probably a,
a polyvinyl chloride plastic.
Also,
the doors are commonly plastic.
Uh,
the windows,
the window frames are plastic.
And,
uh,
how do they seel when your door shuts?
Uh,
it doesn't,
uh,
shut with a hard plastic meeting,
hard plastic.
It's kind of separate alliance that lies the next to the door,
uh,
that will absorb the shock and also it will prevent a heat from escaping.
So generally with a a window,
you'll have several different kinds of plastic.
Uh,
the same with,
with doors.
Uh,
the vent that you see on the up here on the near the peak of the roof,
uh,
also would be plastic.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the exterior surfaces of this,
this structure,
uh,
are predominantly made out of plastic.
Many paints also contain plastics,
uh,
within them.
I think also about,
uh,
court or wire.
A wire is generally coated with vinyl polyvinyl chloride.
And,
uh,
just as an as an example,
there are in a new building like a coon hall where I've gotten my office,
there are probably hundreds of miles of electrical conduit,
uh,
that circulate through that single building.
And then think about power lines and the,
uh,
the,
cheating that exists on the power lines.
Uh,
well how many miles of power line do you think there are in the United States?
Well,
one thing you could do is you could just calculate a on,
on a Google type in a number of miles of roads in the United States,
because most roads,
uh,
are also corridors for power lines.
So I would estimate that we probably have hundreds of billions of miles,
uh,
of electrical cable,
a that cheated in polyvinyl chloride,
all of which is not recyclable.
Interestingly,
uh,
the value of,
of copper inside the wire is high enough to encourage it's recycling,
but the value of the PVC is,
is negligible.
And I'd also like you to think about your own water supply.
I think about where you grew up.
Uh,
do you,
do you know where your water came from?
Do you know how it was piped to,
to,
to your,
your faucets?
Well,
here's an example of a water supply being fed by copper pipes at the top,
and then there's a district distribution network throughout the house.
I know going to say they're the refrigerator or going to the kitchen sink,
going to toilets in different parts of the house.
Uh,
well this also,
uh,
is made out of plastic.
Uh,
and you know,
one would think that,
uh,
somebody would have demanded that these chemicals be tested to know,
to understand whether or not they would Leech,
uh,
out of the,
of the lines.
And in many cases,
particularly with newer houses,
you'll have a filtration system and you may have seen these cartridge filtration
systems.
They look like canisters or they come in various sizes.
I've got one in my house that's a sediment filter as as one example,
and it was a,
it was put in before I understood this whole plastics issue.
And I also can tell you that it's almost impossible to find a water filter
that's not made out of plastic.
So within this plastic canister,
it's got a top that screws on.
Uh,
so to change the filtration that you take the filler material out and then you
put a new one in a after a certain number of months so that most water filters,
uh,
also are plastic.
Uh,
also nobody asked the question,
well,
what's leeching out of the,
out of the filters into the waterline?
And I'd like you to think about the vehicle environment and that's kind of
interesting.
You know,
I use the phrase that that people are spending in the United States about 90% of
their time indoors.
Uh,
well it's,
it's about 87% of their time indoors.
And it's about three to 4% of their time within vehicles.
Uh,
and think about the interior cabins of on the upper left here.
uh,
a new vehicle,
a so that this probably has a,
maybe a couple of dozen different polymers in it,
uh,
ranging from the TV screen and all of its components down through the plastic
steering wheel,
the plastic plastic dashboard,
uh,
the plastic console between the seats,
different kinds of plastics in the seat itself,
including the polyurethane foam inside the seat,
uh,
almost,
none of which are recyclable.
So eventually,
uh,
most of these parts that are made out of plastic or simply going to be burned,
which gives off a quite a bit of an energy in an incinerator because of a high
carbon content in the plastic.
So remember that most of these plastics are derived from what,
uh,
their,
their petroleum based,
uh,
so that it's very important to,
to recall that,
that,
uh,
fossil fuels,
the,
uh,
oil,
is being,
uh,
or is the predominant source of,
of plastics,
the interior of a subway or in this case,
an Amtrak train on the upper right also is predominantly plastic,
uh,
as is the interior of an airline cabin.
Uh,
and this is all for,
uh,
an interesting and really important purpose and that is to lighten the weight of
the vehicle.
So 30 years ago,
vehicles were much heavier than they are today.
So an average vehicle today might be 2,500 pounds.
Uh,
but,
uh,
an average vehicle,
perhaps,
uh,
40 years ago,
was,
uh,
perhaps a three or 400 pounds.
More than that.
Indeed,
there are about 300 pounds of plastic and every new vehicle,
and it's a pretty much guaranteed that that material would not be recycled.
Also,
I'd like you to think about a coatings,
a whole idea of coding things.
I've realized that really late in my,
uh,
in my career that I hadn't,
I hadn't paid any attention to coatings.
But if you think about the number of buildings,
uh,
that are,
that exist in the world,
the number of buildings in the United States,
uh,
I think like a,
say Sherman Williams,
the paint industry.
You know what?
There a phrase is,
you know what their corporate motto is?
Uh,
the corporate motto was covered the earth.
And you see this red paint a,
their symbol as red paint that is flowing down across a,
the top of a globe.
Uh,
well think about the surface area.
A simply have this room.
Think about the surface area in your house.
Uh,
the flooring,
uh,
think about,
the walls.
Think about the ceiling.
And if you're an executive for a paint company,
you're thinking,
oh my gosh,
we have such a huge market.
Everybody is going to want to paint something a different color.
Uh,
and,
uh,
should we make the paints,
to be a more stable or not quite as stable so that they will,
uh,
want to repaint after a certain number of years.
So just as another example,
I've done this myself.
I've refinished floors,
which is a pretty nasty business.
You don't want to just spend much of your life a refinishing a floor,
especially if you are addressed,
such as this gentleman is a with no respirator on because he's breathing in a
pretty nasty mixture of dust that include of course the wood flooring,
but it also includes a plastic,
uh,
the polyurethanes that are put down on the floor.
You can see them right here up on the podium.
You can see the shiny coating on top of the desk and you can see it also on the,
uh,
the desks on the side of your chairs so that the number of surface coatings in
the world is enormous in Area A and we don't really think about,
uh,
the,
the long term consequences of that.
What would happen if we didn't code the surfaces?
What,
what happened to the floor?
I mean,
could you wash it?
Uh,
could you,
uh,
not put a coating like a polyurethane or a varnish on walls like this?
I mean,
would it,
uh,
with a decay or break down more quickly?
And the answer is no.
A,
and I've been wondering about that and I've been wondering about are,
uh,
the origin of our aesthetic of,
of smoothness.
We love smooth things.
You know,
whether or not it's skin,
uh,
whether or not it's a surface,
if something is rough and harsh and it has a negative attitude toward it.
So if you're in the business of making these coatings,
you,
you play on that also,
if you're in the business of selling cosmetics,
but you also play on that.
What about other sources?
I've mentioned a fragrances in the past.
Uh,
these two contained plasticizers,
a diet for Alfalfa.
It has been found in a number of,
of,
uh,
common perfumes as well as,
in some air fresheners and also think about other kinds of products in your
life.
Now,
why is a diaper absorbent?
Uh,
why is a personal hygiene product absorbent?
Well,
this diaper has probably a two or three different kinds of plastic within it.
And what's going to happen to this?
We'll certainly,
it's not going to be recycled.
Uh,
it's likely to be burned or,
or,
or buried.
I think about where you sleep.
Uh,
what is your mattress made out of?
Anybody here know exactly what your mattress is made out of.
Now,
it's a very difficult thing to discover.
Again,
there's no requirement to label the content of your mattress or your pillow.
You get a,
a,
a broad description of it and like a polyester filled a polyurethane foam.
But you really don't,
you really don't know what the,
the,
uh,
environmental fate of these compounds might be.
So what I'm doing is I'm painting a picture for you here that we're all as,
as innocent.
You're all as innocent as I am.
And thinking that,
well,
somebody must've been paying attention to this.
Uh,
nobody would,
would really want us to be,
uh,
lying with our noses,
within a half an inch of a surface where we had no understanding of what the
chemical content is.
Think about toys,
90% of the toys produced in the world.
Now,
you know,
between 80% and 90% are produced in China,
and increasingly they're made out of plastic.
Uh,
you know,
consider yourself to be the executive of a Mcdonald's a and you're thinking
about the introduction of a new meal,
a new supersize meal,
or maybe an environmentally responsible downsize meal.
What are you going to do?
Well,
one of the first things you're going to do is you're going to try to,
to contract out with a toy manufacturer to try to figure out what the next toy
is going to be that you're going to give for free.
Uh,
so all the children,
when they come to Mcdonald's,
I will sit in and play with a toy while they,
they,
uh,
eat their hamburger.
Well,
what happens to those toys?
Uh,
the overwhelming majority of them get discarded within a week of,
of when they're,
when they're issued a,
and these also are not recycled.
Think about your own entertainment,
uh,
what you purchase.
And by the way,
all of these toys are wrapped in plastic,
uh,
of different forms.
And to think about the polycarbonate CD disk,
uh,
that,
the,
the number of CD disks that you have lying around your house or your apartment
or your dorm room,
and think about how you,
how you,
uh,
bought it.
Well,
it came in,
uh,
a cover that looks something like this and it probably was also wrapped in some,
other additional kind of a vinyl coating,
plastic coating on the outside.
Uh,
that makes it actually difficult to,
to get the discount at least within the store in a,
in an unobtrusive manner.
So,
you know,
think,
think about your iPhone.
So think about your iPods,
think about your computers.
Uh,
think about your electronic world.
I want to talk a little bit more about food because food is,
it turns out,
uh,
is now believed to be the predominant source of chemical components in plastic
that are now measurable and human,
a human tissues.
And I'd like you to think also about the way that we store food,
uh,
the way that we buy food,
the way that it's processed and how it's,
uh,
how it's packaged and sold.
And it's done in very specific ways to promote its freshness and to avoid a food
borne illnesses.
Uh,
and this is very important,
but we haven't been thinking ecologically about how to manage this problem,
uh,
because,
really,
uh,
no one has designed these products so that,
the end of the life fate is,
is,
uh,
being considered,
indeed that no,
no producer really has a responsibility for a disposal or the ultimate fate of
the product.
I think also about your electronic world with respect to computers.
I became fascinated when I read that,
uh,
a printer I was using,
had ink in it.
Uh,
and the ink,
I mean,
obviously the printer is,
is a foreign predominantly out of plastic or different kinds of plastics,
uh,
including the electronics board.
Uh,
but I didn't know that,
uh,
the ink itself could have plastic in it.
Why would ink have plastic in it?
Well,
it turns out that the plastic and Biz Faena lay has an effect on paper,
that it prevents the ink from spreading into the fibers of the paper once it's
applied.
This is apparently a more common with,
uh,
the inkjet printers or the,
the,
uh,
heat driven printers that you get as a credit card receipt.
I think also about,
uh,
bisque Faena lay and polycarbonates and a,
the next generation of,
uh,
water bottles and containers.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
many people have recognized now,
that when infants are fed formula,
uh,
it's very common for a,
a mom or a dad or whoever to fill up a bottle,
a plastic bottle,
uh,
either with hot water or to put it in the microwave.
So that the idea that a heating,
uh,
of,
of these,
uh,
products could energize the molecules and,
and cause some of them to,
uh,
migrate into the,
the,
the food or the liquid itself.
Uh,
this,
this was not tested.
It was not required to be tested in a sufficient way by the food and Drug
Administration.
Although the food and Drug Administration has the legal authority to do so.
And so what,
what I'm doing is painting a picture here that the environmental protection
agency has the responsibility to implement the toxic substance control act.
They have not required prior testing.
They have not demanded that to hazardous components.
Uh,
those chemicals that are found to adversely affect the health of other species
that they be eliminated from the product.
And there's no labeling involved either in the,
uh,
country of origin or in the chemical composition of the product.
So there's absolutely no way that the consumer has to discriminate between safe
and unsafe or environmentally responsible products.
Also,
I want you to think a little bit more about,
uh,
what we drink from.
And uh,
many of these containers,
uh,
have some,
fibers,
uh,
plant material in them,
but they are often coated with plastic as well.
This is a typical grocery store,
uh,
on the next time you walk into a supermarket,
I hope you walk down the isles and I want you to just pay,
pay to pay special attention and look particularly for products that are not
wrapped in plastic or they're not stored in plastic environments.
And the same thing goes with respect to coke.
I gave a lecture similar to,
to this,
uh,
several months ago,
and that was,
I was struck,
a gentleman came up,
uh,
after the lecture,
he was a,
a very heavy set guy and,
and uh,
he said,
you know,
I drink a three to four liters of,
of,
uh,
a soda every day.
And he said,
and I'm worried about from what you said,
I'm worried about the,
the plastic chemicals migrating into,
uh,
into liquids and,
and whether or not it's building up in my body and I'm thinking of the three to
four liters of soda per day.
Uh,
that's not good for,
with respect to the sugar alone.
And,
uh,
he said,
well,
from what you said,
uh,
the,
the internal lining of the cans is lined with an epoxy resin that often contains
Biz Faena lay now,
and should I choose to drink coke in cans or should I drink the coke out of
these liter bottles that are made out of polyethylene?
Well,
I said to him,
I thought that for a couple minutes.
And I said,
well,
you know,
I think I would avoid the cans.
Uh,
because of the,
at least the polyethylene does not have a,
a,
a hormonally active compound in it's such as Biz Faena light.
Well,
he was,
he was not pleased about the story,
but it gives you some insight into the way that the epoxy resins are being used
in order to prevent oxidization on the inside of all sorts of cans,
canned tomatoes.
Uh,
think about your dining hall.
And if you work in the dining hall,
think about the large cans that they,
they,
uh,
have their food delivered within.
Uh,
and,
uh,
all of these are potential sources of exposure.
I think of the way that meets or packaged,
uh,
that,
are wrapped in vinyl.
They're sitting on polystyrene,
none of which is recycled.
What happens when you get your food home while you bring it into her
refrigerator and where do you store it?
You store it inside plastic bins,
uh,
and uh,
and my refrigerator,
it looks quite a bit like this.
And what she,
what I did didn't,
I'm not showing you here is the water supply.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
some refrigerators have a,
a,
a little interior cutout in the front door where you push a push of glass into
it to get a fresh water or,
or it's an ice dispenser.
Uh,
so that tracing the origin of the water to that,
uh,
will lead you to plastic tubing,
which is made out of of a,
a Thali,
uh,
could be,
this phenotype.
What happens to all these products once we get rid of them?
Well,
you know,
it's kind of ironic that we take them out.
We put them in a plastic trash bin.
I just walked in,
uh,
past Vanderbilt hall and a,
you all know the walkway and there were about 15 or 20 different plastic garbage
cans all lined up.
What happens to those when they crack,
uh,
w where do they end up?
Uh,
similarly,
most will end up in either underground or they will end up in incinerators.
I think about sports.
I was thinking about Lindsey Vaughn,
uh,
and as I was,
skiing over Christmas break,
I thought about my own,
uh,
my own gear that I had on.
I had plastic skis on.
I had plastic boots on.
I had a plastic polycarbonate helmet on.
I had plastic goggles on,
on top of my polycarbonate plastic lenses.
I had,
uh,
a Gore Tex jacket on.
I had waterproof pants on that not only were synthetic and,
and,
uh,
formed at least in part on a plastic,
but they also had been applied with a,
uh,
a waterproofing agent that a we talked about earlier.
I,
Hey,
a compound,
uh,
that,
basically is designed to prevent a molecules from resting on them,
uh,
so that,
they shed water,
they shed stains,
stain resistant chemicals,
uh,
and,
and also,
uh,
I had,
underwear that was a long underwear that was made out.
A police,
uh,
fleeces is polyethylene often and a fleece actually can be recycled so that some
people claim,
such as Patagonia,
that they use a certain percentage of recycled polyethylene when they make some
of their products.
Uh,
the polls who themselves are made often out of plastic as are the,
the,
uh,
the handles and,
and the,
the baskets.
So that just about any sport you can imagine is now dependent quite heavily on
plastic.
Uh,
the sleds that they use,
a sled that won the games the other night for the u s,
uh,
has an outer shell that would be polycarbonate,
so it would have reduced weight,
but,
but great strength by the way.
You know,
I really appreciated a plastic in,
in,
in my car about,
uh,
two years ago I was driving down 95 and I was rear ended by a maniac who is
going about 95 miles an hour.
The police estimated,
and I was doing about 70 or 75.
Uh,
but,
uh,
my car,
survived quite well.
It was a Toyota,
uh,
and,
the Toyota,
uh,
absorb the shock and the back,
fish tail back and forth in the,
in the passing lane and eventually brought my car over.
I got out and looked at the back and the back end was all banged up and smashed
up.
And,
uh,
that's when I realized,
boy,
you know,
they really have a system down here with these collapsible bumpers,
uh,
where they have different kinds of plastic that are lined up that have different
degrees of hardness in them,
uh,
to basically distribute the energy from a crash.
So the,
the,
uh,
the use of a plastic compounds for their lightness,
for their energy conservation,
for their safety.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
it is clearly growing in,
in,
uh,
public acceptance.
Uh,
think also about the other recreational equipment.
Many of you may have a camelback,
uh,
what's in a camelback anyway?
Well,
it's a plastic bladder made from polyurethane,
uh,
but it contains no [inaudible] or no thalates or there is an antimicrobial
silver lining.
So when people started realizing that they didn't want to buy the sport bottles
such as Nalgene because of this Faena lay,
Kamal back was a,
was quite fortunate that they had chosen a different material and think about
stainless steel bottles,
uh,
such as these clean canteens.
Uh,
these are not aligned with an epoxy resin that contains Biz Faena lay.
And I told you the story about my own well water.
Uh,
but this is a good example here of a,
a tank that also has a,
uh,
this is my water supply,
a tank that has a,
an epoxy resin coating on the inside.
And then the over here on the right hand side,
you can see that canister,
that water filter that I was describing to you earlier.
I think about the Britta filter system built Britta also is made out of a
plastic polycarbonate and also a styrene.
And if you pay attention to the food,
drug and cosmetic act and the safe drinking water act,
you know,
that,
uh,
bottled water curiously is under the jurisdiction of the food and Drug
Administration.
Whereas EPA is responsible for tap water.
That really doesn't make a whole lot of sense.
There's a separate set of compounds that one might expect in bottled water,
uh,
based upon the potential for,
for,
uh,
the compounds to Leech,
from,
uh,
the plastic into the water.
So overall,
uh,
the plastic problem is that it surrounds us.
Uh,
we live in it,
we eat from it,
we drink it,
we play with it,
we work with it.
We listened to it,
we watch it.
Uh,
we cook in it.
So what,
where is this material going in the environment?
Uh,
for one of the fal eight's the DEHP I mentioned earlier.
here's an example of mean concentrations.
Detectable.
Now in the environment,
it's detectable and surface water.
It's detected in groundwater.
It's detected in drinking water.
It's in sediments,
in the bottoms of lakes as well as streams and rivers.
It's found commonly in soils.
It's found,
especially in soils that are beneath landfills.
So when we buried the plastic material,
nobody thought about,
you know,
how,
how bad the soil contamination might get,
how concentrated,
uh,
and where it might migrate.
And could it get down into the underlying aquifer.
It's found in indoor air 109 nanograms per cubic meter.
It's found an outdoor air,
which to me is really quite surprising.
Again,
this is a function of the sensitivity of the detection technology.
Uh,
but this is really,
uh,
quite a,
a,
a comment on our neglect of chemicals and misunderstanding there.
Their movement through the environment and their ultimate fate.
It's detectable inside in house dust.
It's detectable in wastewater.
Uh,
that should be no surprise.
And why would that be?
Oh my gosh.
I mean,
we're feeding our,
our,
uh,
we're feeding ourselves with water,
that's coming in in pipes that are made out of plastics and then we're disposing
of waste,
the drain pipes themselves or polyvinyl chloride.
Uh,
so why wouldn't you find residues in the,
in the wastewater?
And for me,
in one way,
this is a maybe the most disturbing,
uh,
it's in the rainwater,
so that it's detectable and rainwater just the same way that strontium 90 was
detectable and rainwater.
So here's a,
here's a case where we've got an industry that,
that,
uh,
basically,
has,
uh,
a legal framework that,
you know,
uh,
most of the other chemical companies like tobacco,
pesticides,
uh,
pharmaceutical companies,
I mean,
they would,
they would kill to have a legal license such as,
as a is being enjoyed by the,
the plastics industry.
This is a,
uh,
an example of,
of,
uh,
serious,
failure.
And it will be a really interesting kind of a longer term research project if
anybody's looking for a senior essay down the road to,
to ask the question,
especially if you're interested in political science,
why wouldn't this industry be more heavily regulated than it is?
How did they escape control?
How do they fly underneath the radar screen?
Again,
I'm remembering it reminded of Dustin Hoffman's film,
the graduate where,
where,
uh,
a,
a middle aged guy walks up to Dustin Hoffman and,
uh,
pulls him aside at a party where Mrs. Robinson is hovering around in the
background,
uh,
next to the pool.
And he walks up and he says,
I have one,
one word for you son.
Uh,
and it's,
it's plastics.
Now.
This was back in the mid 1960s.
Uh,
so that we've had this explosion of an industry that's gotten into,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of different products.
Uh,
the chemical's plastic chemicals gotten into the products they've made their way
into our life.
And,
you know,
most of us have recognized what's plastic generally and what's not a,
but we really haven't thought about what it might mean for either our health or
environmental quality.
So I want to spend just a couple of minutes,
uh,
having you think about the,
the hormonal question that's being raised by,
by,
uh,
plastics.
And this was,
uh,
first recognized by Rachel Carson.
And,
and when,
when she wrote silent spring and back in 1962 and I've mentioned this on
occasions before,
but not with respect to hormonally active compounds where she discovered a,
along with colleagues that that,
uh,
exposure to a variety of pesticides that were hormonally active,
prevented calcium metabolism in eggshells so that it caused reproductive failure
in certain species,
especially large raptors.
Well,
you know,
that concept that we need to worry about reproductive effects of,
of,
uh,
some of these chemicals.
It really escaped much attention on the part of government through the majority
of the 60s,
uh,
in 1970s and a,
the 1980s.
And then in 1996,
Thiel Colburn,
uh,
who also was a wildlife ecologist like Rachel Carson,
wrote our stolen future.
So if you're interested in,
in,
uh,
this history,
I would encourage you to read our stolen future.
Uh,
it's,
it's written as a kind of a mystery story,
scientific detective story they say in their subtitle.
Uh,
but she wrote this with Diane do Menosky a,
a long time reporter with the Boston Globe,
uh,
and John Myers,
who also was a wildlife ecologist.
If you want to follow this,
uh,
in more detail,
I recommend a Ted Schettler,
uh,
Ted Chandlers and Gina Solomon's a book called generations at risk.
So thinking about,
uh,
how our fertility might be affected by these chemicals that are,
that we're experiencing and mixtures,
uh,
without,
without our knowledge,
without our consent.
This is really the subject of,
of uh,
uh,
most of these books.
So I want to look more carefully at one of these compounds.
Biz Faena lay a because it's one that,
uh,
I think,
almost everybody now has detectable levels of BPA in their tissues and it's now
recognized to Leech from containers.
Uh,
it's soils and surface waters and,
and fish,
uh,
in it's highest in kids aged one to fix.
Oh,
that's really pretty curious.
Why would it be highest?
And Kids ages one to six,
uh,
experts inside EPA and FDA now believe that food and beverages are the dominant
sources of exposure.
By the way,
there is no yet a good answer to the question why the kids are or more heavily
exposed the effects in animals,
uh,
include a female reproductive track abnormalities,
including
abnormalities in the ovary,
uh,
and,
abnormalities of the track,
uh,
reproductive track and in a older female mice and a changed vaginal morphology
among a post pubertal loss offspring.
And it also influences the male reproductive system in different species,
including reduced sperm production.
Uh,
reduced my testes,
wait a an enhanced anal genital distance.
It also has been shown to induce mammary gland development in mice.
So,
you know,
thinking about this chemical and thinking about the different decision making
standards that exist in different environmental laws that we've got.
Um,
I'm curious about this and that if this Faena a,
uh,
we're being sold as a biocide,
as a,
as a pesticide,
EPA could not possibly a license this chemical for use the persistence of the
chemical.
It's environmental fate.
Uh,
its,
its threat to health as evidence by these studies.
I would be significant enough to prevent that from happening.
It's also been associated more recently,
uh,
with insulin resistance,
raising questions about diabetes.
And also there is some evidence of impaired immune function.
Now think about,
uh,
the fact that,
you know,
we're all being exposed to hormonally active chemicals and mixtures,
uh,
without really understanding it.
We don't really know what the intensity of our exposure is.
So what are we seeing out there in terms of fertility,
uh,
or,
or diseases of reproduction in humans?
What we're seeing a rise in the prevalence of infertility,
a serious rise over the past several decades.
And,
uh,
we're also seeing a rise in some,
negative effects in humans and in males,
particularly in young males,
uh,
increase in Hypospadias,
which means that the,
the opening of the penis,
uh,
does not occur at the end of the penis that occurs further up the shaft.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
cryptorchidism which means that,
little kids don't have fully descended testicles,
uh,
when they're born.
So that there are a variety of different reproductive problems occurring in the
population at higher incidence than formerly.
Well,
it's curious when a debate like this occurs when a product is out there in the
marketplace.
Uh,
it's,
it's a traded globally.
Uh,
w what do we about it?
Well,
the government,
the regulatory agencies tend to,
uh,
call in experts and get expert opinions.
So the National Institute for Environmental Health Sciences and I,
EHS a convened a panel.
It turned out,
uh,
the,
the panel was,
was uh,
uh,
put together and some of the reading materials were put together by some
representatives of,
of uh,
the,
the industry itself.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it had a view that many had a view that this was not really an independent
analysis of what the effects of this fenal a might be.
And they concluded with a,
the phrase that there is some concern,
uh,
that exposure to this funeral eight causes some of these reproductive problems.
A second panel was convened a of independent scientists that had no connections
to the plastics industry or the Biz fenal a industry at all.
And they concluded something quite different.
The wide range of adverse effects of low doses of BPA in laboratory animals
exposed both during development and adulthood is a source for concern with
regard to the potential for similar adverse effects in humans.
So that this idea that a,
you take a question of science and,
and you,
you raise it in front of a group of experts,
a really forces one to think carefully about what the conflicts of interest
might be for those experts.
How could you put together a committee that that clearly was independent?
Well,
full disclosure is one way of doing that.
Uh,
so the demanding that people disclose their income tax records or dis disclose
their affiliations or their consulting relationships with,
with different industries,
uh,
could clarify from the public's mind,
whether or not there's a high probability of a bias.
Well,
remember what I said about Bisphenol a being the hardener,
uh,
the fal late,
DEHP is a softener.
Uh,
it's produced in a much lower volume 260 million pounds per year.
It's also found in a,
in our bodies,
it's added to PVC plastic and it's recycling percentage,
uh,
is,
close to zero.
And it also is,
is widely found in the environment and it's been found with a similar kinds of
adverse effects in,
in,
uh,
males in,
in test animals,
including reduced sperm production,
uh,
and early onset of puberty.
Uh,
and all of this exposure is coming predominantly because of the failure of the
toxic substance control act.
So,
you know,
Congress really recognized that we needed a test these chemicals before they
made their way into the market,
uh,
back in,
in the early 1970s.
So they passed a Tosca and gave the authority to EPA to demand premarket
testing,
but they didn't do anything about it.
So again,
the universe of chemicals is big.
82,000 chemicals traded in commerce.
They have some commercial value,
uh,
about 20,000 of those were added since 1986.
And what that means is that this statute,
the way it's worded,
it granted exemptions as,
uh,
chemicals that were grandfathered protected in the marketplace.
They couldn't be removed by EPA to 62,000 different compounds.
Uh,
the statute is unusual also because it places a high burden on EPA to
demonstrate that there's a significant date danger,
uh,
before it can cause the industry,
demand from the industry that they produced the evidence.
Now just like pharmaceuticals and like pesticides and other products that we've
talked about,
you know,
how much sense does it make to have the industry,
uh,
producing the data themselves and then presenting their case to the Mammal
Protection Agency,
uh,
for licensing.
Uh,
where should this occur?
Should there be some sort of an independent organization set up a that would be
more protected from potential bias?
Well,
clearly there's a,
an economic stake involved in industry is anxious to,
to spend that money.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this high burden on EPA to demonstrate danger is the primary reason for the
failure of the toxic substance control act.
So that,
uh,
over this period of time,
they have demanded testing for only 200 different chemicals.
And out of those 200,
only five have been prohibited.
So what are states and other governmental agencies doing about this?
Well,
a variety of state initiatives,
including a hearing Connecticut had been launched.
Uh,
and a number of us had been involved in drafting legislation that in,
in a different states,
uh,
but here in Connecticut,
we now have a statute on the books as of last year that,
uh,
requires that a Biz Faena lay be taken out of products that are intended to be
used by a young children.
Uh,
and similar statutes have been passed in these other states.
You can think about a regulatory policy being one of,
well,
testing a chemical,
figuring out how dangerous it is,
and then figuring out how you might regulate it.
Or you might just say,
here's a clear threshold.
If a chemical behaves in this way,
say it's persistent,
it's bioaccumulative,
it's found in human tissues and it's demonstrated to be hormonally active.
But that's it.
It's out of the marketplace.
That's a prohibitive policy.
So once you decide not to employ a prohibitive policy,
once you decide not to ban,
you basically,
uh,
require the regulatory agency,
to figure out,
uh,
you know exactly which uses would be allowed and which would not.
And it creates a very expensive and difficult time consuming,
uh,
monitoring and enforcement.
Uh,
problem for an agency.
So,
uh,
the regulation chemical by chemical use by use,
is not likely to have much effect in,
in that,
uh,
solving a problem such as this California is requiring the listing of DEHP under
its proposition 65,
uh,
and this,
was required in 2008.
And what it's done is it's limited,
uh,
the concentration of DEHP,
in products to less than 0.01%.
Now what would that do?
You're going to limit the of a chemical and a product to 0.01,
2%.
That's going to force the government into becoming,
uh,
monitoring organization.
So it's got to go out and it's got a test in order to find products that,
that do not comply.
Again,
very expensive and a strategy that's not likely to work.
Now,
the European Union is,
is taking a very different approach.
Uh,
they are,
uh,
they have adopted a law in 2006,
known as reach in reach requires toxicity and environmental fate testing,
uh,
for 1500 of the highest volume chemicals,
the highest,
uh,
amount produced,
among the 80,000 chemicals that are out there that are poorly tested.
Uh,
it,
it's,
uh,
also a program that's been delayed.
The endocrin screening program,
uh,
will not begin until 2012.
Uh,
the mixture problem remains the,
they still are not going to tackle the,
the,
uh,
issue that we're exposed to mixtures that might act by the same mechanism.
Uh,
and also they will be grandfathering many of the chemicals that are produced in
the smaller quantities.
What,
why would it not make sense to focus exclusively on the high production volume
chemicals?
Well,
you've got to think about the fact that there could be some chemicals that are
extremely potent and extremely dangerous at very low doses.
So plutonium,
again,
is,
is a good example of that.
Also corporations are acting on their own.
So that PVC corporate phase out policies and been adopted by a variety of firms,
including these,
and this is having a very significant effect.
Number one,
it's educating.
A lot of people when they see a label that says PVC free a or BPA free,
they,
they start to pay attention and ask questions.
Why that,
uh,
why that might be a,
and I want you to back up and I want you to think about really what the core of
this problem is.
It really is consumerism.
Uh,
the fact that,
uh,
you know,
we buy much more than than we need.
We don't pay attention in a way to,
uh,
the ingredients of different products that we bring into our environment.
Uh,
it also has to do with,
uh,
you know,
the ignorance of our effects of our own behavior.
I,
while I was preparing this lecture over the past couple of days,
I have to admit that I got really angry with myself.
I got angry and I got surprised because I,
I think of myself as,
as somebody that should have known better,
I should have adjusted my lifestyle to what I recognized as a potential threat,
not just to the environment,
not just to the population,
but,
uh,
to,
to my own kids.
So,
you know,
there are many reasons for that that don't have to do with me.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I should have known better than that.
And,
uh,
hopefully after taking this course,
you will,
you will not make this,
this kind of problem yourself.
You can think about a national regulation,
uh,
as a partial solution because the markets are global.
People are trading these products and chemicals across national borders all the
time.
So what does it mean if the United States passes a law?
Uh,
but,
uh,
say Germany does not pass a law or Germany's got a more restrictive statute than
the United States.
That's a recipe for trade barriers that are likely to be eventually litigated.
So think also about,
uh,
the concentration and,
and dispersion of products and the,
the,
the effect of one corporation like Mcdonald's or,
uh,
are say Toyota,
to,
to make a choice that they are going to,
uh,
not use certain products,
that they're not going to distribute a billion new toys over the next two years
where their new market line or that they're going to demand a ultimate
accountability for the eventual fate or end of life of their product.
The way that some of the printer companies have,
uh,
that have demanded the recycling,
or not demanded,
but,
but offered,
uh,
to,
to take back the ink cartridges once they are,
uh,
empty.
So basically the government has been neglecting extra towels and externalities
and there's been an absence of,
uh,
accountability.
So here's a list of potential solutions and I know we're out of time,
uh,
go through these.
These will be up on the website later this afternoon.
So I'm going to conclude there and just remind you that,
uh,
the,
the electronic exam will be emailed out to you today at five o'clock,
uh,
that you have 48 hours to return it and return it both to the classes Vitu
server,
Dropbox,
but also please return it to your teaching assistants.
Thanks very much and good luck and I probably won't see many of you before
break,
so I hope you have a really great break.